[Music]
foreign
hey everybody it's Monday and here we
are talking about a haunting two minutes
late too Jenny yelling at me well you
know I had to go get some ice well like
I said it's like I never know what he's
doing and it's just kind of like and he
always like Waits until the absolute
last minute and then he's just like
wanders off and I don't know where he
was and I'm just like all kinds of stuff
man am I gonna start the show without
you I'm juggling ice ice supply sugar
well you should have done that like a
long time ago
for me
the rest of the world has to like live
it happens so it's like you need to
learn to do that [__] too we're all
prepared what are you doing you're just
like wandering around okay but yeah so
uh yeah so this is an episode that we
talked about before way in the hell back
on episode
47. yeah I think it might have been
um but you know we liked this one a lot
and we wanted to cover it again uh you
know because it's kind of unusual in the
annals of a haunting plus it has the
where is that raccoon dude yeah he's an
actor that said I had totally forgotten
that you yeah he's not in it much but
you know he's it's not like a star turn
like uh like the haunting of Summerwind
was yeah he plays the the husband
so he gets to be like a little bit he
gets to have like a little bit of a rant
in this where he's like yelling about
the the ghost stories well what he's
yelling about the electric bill first I
was just kind of like it's does this
have anything to do with the raccoon sir
because I think like it might also he's
one of those look man I don't have time
for ghosts all right
to be fair tell me about what the ghost
is
one of those guys
this family that moves to Taiwan
and uh they seem pretty credible you
know upper class family they go to
Taiwan for some business uh Arrangement
that the husband has with what I forgot
what kind of company it was
um I don't think they ever mentioned to
be honest uh if they did I didn't write
it down yeah
the matriarch of the family
she said that Taiwan was a lawless
country I think we laughed about that in
the first time you don't know Brazil I
was like of all the Lawless countries in
the world I'm like pretty sure Taiwan is
like close to the bottom of the list I
mean I've never been there but just from
my own perception he might be able to
get wild yeah it's like
[__] I I grew up partially in Brazil
man and that was a damn and a narco
tyranny it was Anarchy all right that
was lawless there
uh no [__] Taiwan I just never
imagined well she just meant that it
wasn't a laws she was used to well I
yeah because I kind of feel like like
you know no no hate against the people
this was a long time ago but um I don't
know I just I kind of feel like they
they came across as a little bit prissy
to me yeah yeah you know what I mean
they're rich people yeah like like they
were very very used to of specific like
way of life and anything other than that
they were like ew yeah yeah you know
what I mean they were kind of like that
like ooh the poor they kind of came
across like that to me Maybe not maybe
they're lovely people I don't know but
that was just like the impression that I
got you know
I just I'm very sensitive to that
because I you know I grew up like really
poor and I even went to school with like
the people that weren't even as rich as
these people but they had that kind of
like thing toward like if you live in a
trailer park or you have secondhand
shoes or some [__] like that they're
very ew a poor you know they're very
much like that so I'm very like uh alert
to that kind of uh attitude you know
what I mean and that's how these people
kind of came across like I said I don't
know I don't know them but you know what
I mean I'm indifferent to everything I
don't care what other people say no I'm
just saying yeah I don't care about it
either it's just that you you you
recognize it that's what I mean you
recognize that tone like even if people
are trying to be nice to you there's
always like that little piece of
condescension I just always I just you
know I [__] I went to school with
people like that you know when I'm up in
Brazil you know the school of graduated
some follow it's the [__] most
expensive High School in Brazil
president of Brazil's kids go there and
the [__] ex-king of Brazil's kids
girl going there he would have been King
his name is Louise I got pictures of him
by yearbook anyway
what's funny is that the real rich ones
weren't like that it was the ones that
were kind of the more the poorer of the
rich people were like that the real rich
people were like gangsters they didn't
give a [__]
but um I don't know I'm getting off
track but I'm just saying what else do
you think I'm just saying
it never it never impressed me was
always a sign of it was just another
version of being parochial
that's all it was you know well
sheltered Pro yeah parochial and and not
really exposed to anything outside a
very small sphere
so they have money and they education
and sophistication but not very much um
experience with anything you know so if
it's well they're shielded from a lot of
things in the world that a lot that most
other people have to experience and have
to like fight their way through I well I
I remember hearing about this because I
read uh there's a great book called
watching the English which is written by
a British woman and she's writing about
English culture as though she's like an
anthropologist you know what I mean um
and like talking about all their little
traditions and stuff and one of the
things that she mentioned was that even
though the class system is like you know
rather prevalent in the UK she's like
people that have like a real a [__] ton
of money are just kind of like they just
drive old beater cars like they don't
give a [__] they're like it's always the
people that are a tear or two down from
that that are the worst because they're
the ones that are aspirational and they
have like things to prove to other
people like look how rich I am you know
what I mean like so it's that kind of
thing that's basically what I said yeah
so it's like you know people that have
always had money and you know that they
don't really have the need to like prove
it it's like a burden to them they don't
give a [__] so it's so it's that but
like I said I mean you know we kind of
got far afield but I did kind of just
they're just starting to come in anyway
just that comment that the woman made on
this show about Taiwan being Lawless I
just thought that was very funny now I
think they did I don't think they went
all that into this but I'm pretty sure
they mentioned that they had moved
they're an American family but they had
moved from Tokyo so they had been living
in Tokyo
um and then moved to Taiwan because his
job like he got a transfer or something
like that so but I don't know compared
to compared to Japan
Taiwan is Lawless I don't really know
Taiwan might be corrupt uh there's
probably things like prostitution and
[__] that's kind of technically illegal
but they still do it they do that
everywhere but like they do that
everywhere yeah like that's no more
Lawless than any other place right well
I I know that there was like uh
some terrorism where some guys took some
people hostage but that happens and you
know and then they shot it out with the
police it also happens that really
happens everybody you know being an
American she should be used to [__] like
that because that [__] happens all the
time here just it's always far away
people don't realize how people don't
live here don't realize how far away all
that [__] is from you you don't see it
you know
it's always in some other state
very rarely do you see it up close
although that pulse shooting happened up
the street from us yeah and we were
actually out there that was just like
two blocks away yeah
yeah it was weird
but it just comes and goes it's just the
way to
Zach says I couldn't watch this one as a
kid because the big ass spiders and I
still hate it yeah there's a lot of
tarantulas in this one this is a good
case I think it's credible uh the claims
are not real real
um not real Outlander they're not real
outlandish it's a bad house is what
they're talking about it's bad enough to
wear
there's a there's an entity there of
some sort or at least it appears to be
an entity making voices
it calls the girls and I guess
it infers that it sexually assaults one
of the one of the girls yeah I wasn't
sure that's what they were implying I
mean it's just kind of like that's what
they were implying but it's like I
couldn't just be like reading into it
maybe that ghost had more than one kind
of hunger
well that was kind of the whole premise
of the thing was that they were kind of
going into a little bit like in Asian
cultures I guess they have something
called Hungry ghosts I've also seen this
called Hungry demons which I don't yeah
because when I looked it up I was like I
never heard it called that but maybe
it's called that in other countries it's
called Hungry ghosts in Korea they had a
thing called baby ghost
yeah baby ghost those are the babies
that got thrown up on the mountains
because they're discarded babies late
term abortion
late term abortion just throw them out
yeah which is [__] up yeah
katusa I was working with him Kim he's
curled up on the ground next to me
[__] weird in those mountains he's
[__] shivering and I said it's not
cold man he goes scared see what he's
scared of baby ghost it's like what the
baby goes they tried to [__] explain
it
and I just let the [__] [__] fly says
you're trying to go home because yeah he
says you want to go home yeah miss your
mama don't you yeah you're just like
that
later on I told Corporal song about it
says he's talking about baby ghosts man
what the [__] is a baby this goes oh
baby goes yeah yeah and he explained it
to me but a couple song explain it to me
Kim couldn't tell me what a baby ghost
was he just said it was just his English
wasn't good enough at that time
but uh
interesting story this is the Hungry
Ghost
which is a
it's an it's an Asian ghost
that wants something that can't get it
somebody uh dies in uh
a tragic situation and something was
unresolved but I think that's probably
the all ghosts would end up being that's
what I mean I don't really know why I
think just specifically what they were
saying was that hungry ghosts like not
only died in a violent way or there's
unresolved issues which like you said is
probably like most ghost stories but I
think that they were implying that these
particular ghosts were mad maybe that
they were not alive anymore and they
still wanted things that they would have
wanted when they were living like food
and money and things like that because
that's how you apparently try to appease
them as you bring them [__] like you
know what I mean like you bring them a
pineapple or you break them like
consider the priest company on pineapple
it's like here goes I have a pineapple
this is this this will sort you right
out well they did in Brazil too they
leave yeah offerings and stuff you know
and macumba give them some money it's
like what is a ghost gonna do with money
it's spiritual money because they're
gonna extend in a good or McDonald's and
get a fillets
cigarettes yeah I've seen that too
playing cards
um
chicken
um you know and it'd be like a whole
chicken Dead Chicken in there
um
what is it you said a booze there's like
a bottle of wine there
yeah give them stuff the money though a
lot of times it's not real money
it's like fake money like Monopoly like
Monopoly money time to deal you know you
little kids could buy play money yeah
it's like that that's usually what's in
there but the food and the cigarettes
are real
yeah I've seen that well because they do
that on Day of the Dead too don't they
yeah I think so in Mexico where they
leave like food and stuff food
cigarettes and a chicken yeah you know
inside a bowl it might have some chicken
blood thrown over it depending on
whatever the situation is you think each
one is a different recipe
I don't know what they're trying to do
pack of playing cards somebody needs to
open like a ghost Diner
you know what I mean somebody needs to
open like a ghost Diner yeah you know
what I mean like that that's kind of
like the theme is that you're supposed
to like like ghosts are supposed to come
in there and eat I've seen musical
instruments you know like a harmonica or
a flute or a like a a kid's ukulele you
know stuff like that in there yeah and
all that kind of stuff to you yeah but
yeah they just like leave them so yeah
well like I said it makes sense you know
it's a dead person and it's like they're
kind of still around it's not it's they
just went through the veil you know what
I mean yeah they're still like the same
person so they'd still like the same
[__] I guess giving them knickknacks in
a spirit world to keep them uh keep them
busy that goes all the way back to
ancient Egypt it'll go into the little
tombs of pharaohs and even just workers
and stuff and they'll have little clay
representations of servants and horses
and Clay representations of food
sometimes real food you know it's like
here play with this [__] in here and
like don't haunt us okay pictures of
stuff
it becomes real in the afterlife when
they need it that kind of stuff wait no
it's magical for sure
so uh so yeah with like I said this is
uh season two episode six and we did
talk about this before like I said a
long time ago but that was before we had
a visual component yeah before we could
make gestures at you and stuff like that
so we thought we would just revisit
because you know we have a lot of
episodes still that we haven't done but
I don't know people seem to like the
older ones like especially like the
first four or five seasons and I know
we've done most of those but they're the
iconic ones Man classic ones yeah and I
kind of feel like maybe we should be
revisiting some of the ones that we did
like with our Better Sound and all that
kind of business yeah but now I will say
that I there's not a lot of other
um supplemental material about this
particular case I couldn't really find
anything like other than
somebody posting on Reddit or or some
form somewhere like back in 2009 asking
about whatever happened to this family
but like nobody ever knew anything about
it so I don't really know
uh you know if there's any other
supplemental material if they told their
story it didn't look like anybody had
written a book about it or anything like
that so just telling you that right now
it makes some guests probably
I mean you know how long ago was how
long ago was this show
oh at least 15 years it had to have been
because yeah season two that was
probably like a long time ago and like I
said some of the um some of the uh
messages that I saw about it were from
way back in 2009 so it must have aired
before that I'd imagine what was it 2007
I think was season two maybe
but um apparently they're using their
real names but I guess they're the
bishop family that's uh their last name
so
um Dennis is the dad and Candace was the
mom yeah
so what ends up happening this actually
took place way the hell back in 1984.
so I guess the company that Dennis
worked for it was an American company
apparently but they had offices like all
throughout Asia
and I guess prior to this they had been
living in Tokyo because I'm assuming
that's where he worked before but then
he got asked to transfer to Taipei like
in Taiwan
um so
so they go there and it's like um what
do they call the yangming mountains
that's where the house was I think
that's what I wrote down
and uh yeah he was basically like well
it was kind of a thing where you could
turn the promotion down but if you did
they'd probably be like well you're
fired or you're not getting more money
or something like that so he felt kind
of felt the need to take it
so they moved to Taiwan like I said it's
Dennis and Candace they're the mom and
dad and then they had two kids uh Stacy
who at the time was 16 and Marissa who
at the time was 12.
um I will say that the girl the actress
that they had playing Marissa I think
she was a little bit older than 12. she
looked like she was but she was supposed
to be 12 years old yeah boy she's that
girl's awful immature but then I
realized that she's supposed to be 12.
yeah I think the actress was a couple
years old yeah she's probably about 16
17. something like that but yeah she was
playing a 12 year old
um yeah and then I wrote down Taiwan
Taiwan was lawless which I thought was
very funny yeah uh because that I don't
know that was just something that I know
what they're talking about you said out
to me my family was doing the same kind
of thing you know going to Brazil for
business
and a lot of my peers their families
were kind of like that because this is a
long time ago in the 80s people weren't
they didn't have YouTube they weren't
really sure what other countries were
like so it was I anxiety going to work
in a foreign country and it's different
over there hey you know they don't have
the same laws we have oh that shit's
wild you know that's that's the attitude
oh is it safe to raise our kids there do
they have VCRs
referring back to something I was
talking about on Friday what happens if
they smoke weed over there you know just
that kind of [__] scandalous yeah sure
what if things aren't illegal
what if I see hookers walking around
because I was going to the nightclubs at
[__] 15. that was you know you could
drink it at 15 in Brazil technically
illegal I think 18 was but if nothing is
enforced it is it is anarchy
which is good I love it I love Anarchy
just watch you step they [__] shoot
each other over here well I mean you
know that's not great it just happens
they do that here well yeah I know they
do yeah all that wild [__] you see on
YouTube them weird [__] is most of
that's Brazil
Zach says well I have to use a squat
toilet yeah yeah yeah I'm kind of feel
like that's sort of where I draw the
line gonna say get a real toilet
countries okay
no it's like we've had we've had this
technology for several centuries at this
point get your [__] together
um but yeah so uh so they had moved in
Tokyo now they moved to this place now
the the company like I said I don't know
what Corporation this was but it
apparently was like super like fancy as
[__] because they're like oh we have
this company house that we let like the
executives live in like the guy that had
lived there before I guess he didn't
work there anymore whatever so he had
[__] off but I don't know what the
actual house looked like because
obviously they have like different ones
like on the show but the one they showed
on the show
was like a [__]
that was like a [__] Palace man it
was like a big huge of like it was there
was a bunch of land around it like it
was like right at the base of the
mountains and it was this massive white
it didn't even really look like a house
to be honest with you it kind of looked
like a Bank building or something yeah
that's the way houses looked in Korea
well yeah it looked like that and it was
all glass like on the front and
everything like that so but yeah so they
they get that
and they even have they even have like a
driver they have like a limo and a
driver and all that which I'm assuming
the company paid for as well
which you know that's that's crazy
so they go to this house and the dad and
the K and the daughters are all pretty
jazzed about it because they're like
holy [__] like look at this amazing
Place blah blah blah
but Candace the mom she said that she
had a bad feeling about the place like
before it looked like before she'd even
like walked inside like everybody else
was like running inside going holy [__]
look at this place blah blah but then
she's like standing out of the front
porch like not going in
she's like ooh I'm like I've got a weird
feeling about this and then she said
that before she even walked in she felt
what felt like a fist like slamming hard
into her back like and like knocking her
over like she didn't fall over but like
you know knocked her off balance pretty
much
so she felt like something pushed her
yeah like something shoved her like with
their with their fists
and at this point she's just kind of
like what the [__] like it felt like
something pushed me and then like her
husband was like where is that raccoon
but not really it's the same actor
that's why I keep saying that
um so yeah so she goes in and she's
immediately I don't like this place like
I the actress the way that she was
saying it like because she said it a
bunch of times like through the episode
the actress was just like her inflection
was just like very amusing to me I don't
like this place like she was she sounded
very like whiny yeah so it's like so it
kept like making me laugh like every
time she said it I don't like this but I
don't like this house
um now in her defense though I mean yeah
like it sounded like it goes like
punched her in the kidneys or whatever
but when they go in there
like when the um estate agent or whoever
the [__] is like showing them the house
they said like the walls and this is
like a massive it looks like a Showplace
it's like this big Palace or something
like that I don't know what the real
house looked like but they go in there
and the walls are like kind of like
[__] moldy like discolored and [__]
and they're like um you guys have
problems with like rain like leaking
through the roof or some [__] like that
because this is not acceptable right
here like especially as fancy as yeah
what they're talking about is that in a
lot of countries the uh the entire house
the walls are made of the concrete
concrete blocks and then there's cement
over them and then they're painted real
solid constructions you don't really
need air conditioning either they stay
nice and cool so that's well water if
there if the if the roof is leaking
it can kind of travel down through the
cement
and you can see mold growing on the
cement and that will come out through
the paint and everything yes it's pretty
common if there's cracks or if there's a
leak in there you know the Leaky pipes
inside the concrete walls will
eventually make its way to the surface
I've seen it before
it's a nice house but like it's a very
Eastern house when they showed in the in
the in the series or yeah in in the in
the episode and Jenny's right it's it
wasn't a western layout it was an
Eastern layout
and it does kind of to a Westerner look
like an office building
um but it's because
wealthy families in in the East like
that are going to be extended families
so the owner of the house is going to
have his mom and possibly his dad living
in there with his wife and his kids and
so it's kind of like a series of
apartments and inside the house is what
it's like
which yeah that makes with like a
central part that looks like the center
part of a damn office building yeah like
a hotel like a hotel lobby yes that's
that's kind of that's a good way to
describe it some are laid out kind of
like hotels with lobbies and [__]
Zach says it looked like the kind of
house a Tony Montana type drug lord
thinks is the house a rich person lives
in yeah that's that's very astute that's
that is what it looked like uh but I
actually kind of liked the architecture
of wherever this house was yeah I don't
know where they filmed this I mean
I don't know if they would actually
spend the money to like fly to [__]
Taiwan and like film a house that was
but it did kind of look like a house
like a rich people's house from over
there yeah it looked like a korean house
to me a rich Korean House out in the
country is what it looked like so maybe
that's what they did it maybe it might
have been Korea maybe but yeah I don't
know like like I said I don't know what
their budget is for this kind of [__]
but yeah so they go in and like the
walls are kind of [__] up and uh you
know the the estate agent lady is just
kind of like oh yeah yeah well it's been
like a really bad rainy season we'll
we'll get that like fixed and all this
other kind of [__] and I'm just like
yeah you better but you know at this
point Candace is still like I don't like
this house I don't like this house she
keeps saying so Dennis is like okay
um so you don't like this place so how
about he's like do you want to look for
another house and she's like yes please
so Dennis says that they spent the next
two weeks looking at dozens of other
houses like all around the area so he
did actually like listen to her that she
didn't like the place but like I said
there was other [__] wrong with it like
other than her getting punched in the
back by a ghost or whatever
so he said and I don't I don't know
exactly what this entails but he said
that they looked for a whole bunch of
houses like over two weeks dozens of
houses he said but none of them were as
good or as appropriate or whatever the
hell I don't so I don't know what was
wrong with the other ones but somehow
they ended up at this particular one
which like I said was the company owned
house so that's where they ended up and
Candace was just like well you know this
is best for her husband and he's the one
that's working and bringing in all the
money so she's just gotta like [__]
suck it up but he's the bloke yeah uh
basically and she didn't like it but
what are you gonna do
so uh so yeah so they did that now like
I said they also have a limo which takes
everybody around and they have a guy
that works for them who's like their
driver and I think they said his name
was um aching or uh achong I can't
remember what his name was
I wrote it down but um my handwriting is
[__] up because I was like I was
writing it right his name is aiching or
so or something like that
so the first thing that happens is that
Candace and one of the daughters I can't
remember which one are unpacking like in
the kitchen or whatever and they hear
something in the cabinet like
um so they go in there like gee I wonder
what that is so they open the door and
then like you see like inside the
cabinet Cam and there's like a box of
tea in there and there's a big ass
[__] tarantula like but it's like not
paranormal but it's still like kind of
alarming I guess
so there's a big ass tarantula so
obviously they're just like holy [__]
[__] there's a big ass tarantula so they
call the driver guy and he chases it
with a shovel which I thought was very
funny so he's just like chasing it
through the house so he's chasing the
spider through the house and the spider
is legit making like
a lot of noise like way more noise than
a tarantula would actually make like an
automatic vocalization that's what I
mean it was like I'm like I'm pretty
sure tarantulas don't make batteries
they're not vocalized no I'm pretty sure
they don't
um so so I just thought that was funny
that he was just like going around like
look with the shovel like look at this
[__] spider you know what I mean
um
so then finally he hears like
Granny's just like there you are you
[__] and it's like up on the
wall and he's just like papow and Lee
like hits it with the shovel and then he
comes down with the spider corpse or
whatever like in a big bag or a
pillowcase or whatever and then he tells
the family yeah I got the I got him and
then he says oh well if we saw this one
then there's probably another one
because spiders mate for life and they
always travel in pairs and I said to me
that sounds like some [__] right
there so I actually looked it up earlier
today
because I said that doesn't uh that
doesn't sound right
um they don't but well because one of
the reasons for that is because female
tarantulas can live up to 25 years male
tarantulas only live seven or eight
years male tarantulas
um when they're ready to mate we'll go
over to the female tarantula's house or
her little burrow and we'll kind of like
knock on her little web or door like hey
um sex please and then like the female
tarantula will open the door and be like
all right I'll allow it and then if
she's hungry after but then she'll eat
him yeah so um
a lot of spiders do that so yeah that's
what I mean so yeah tarantulas aren't
the only spiders that do that but um
it's not it's not you know dude is not
aware of this you know I don't think
that this is like yeah I'm gonna go over
there and get this done and just let her
eat me that's not that's not gonna do it
according to
the memory serves the whole thing is
kind of like when they insert their
little packet in there because they
don't even copulate he just pulls out
his [__] pack in a [__] seed and
puts it up in her and [__] inserts it
and evidently just to actually it's like
putting a package in a mailbox yeah
it's not real romantic but they got the
[__] worked out
to where that [__] is so intense for the
[__] spot the male spider that he
he's out of it it's ringing his Bell
he's like oh [__] that was good and so
he's there's in a moment of weakness she
can make a move on him and kill him yeah
but she doesn't always do it no she
doesn't always just always do it
sometimes she's like I will let you live
yeah and then and then he snaps out of
and goes oh I could get the [__] out and
you know Mission accomplishment
package delivered yeah but I guess
there's got to be some kind of a reward
for the spider to put the package in the
mail
right that's what I'm saying because
otherwise why would they think he's like
[__] that I'm just gonna stay home stay
home I'm gonna stay home and like order
pizza and just hang out and watch spider
TV because I'm not going over to that
bitch's house you might eat me see he
just busted nut by just putting it in
there and he's like oh [__] that [__]
was so hot
God damn did you see it that's it oh man
[__] he's losing it you know oh man
it was hot please tell me that somebody
makes tarantula porn sometimes
I'm sure somebody does it's the internet
he's taking a selfie why he's doing it
oh my God I love it get the ankle right
get the ankle
see it and he's smiling in the camera
that is like so [__] funny
oh I just I got so distracted by the
Tarantulas guys I actually quite like
spiders but um
I just thought the whole thing was so
funny like thinking about because when
he comes down and he's all authoritative
oh well there's gonna be another one in
the house because spiders travel in
pairs I'm like you sir are mistaken I'm
pretty sure I'm like I'm gonna look that
up though so I did now I know I realize
that there's lots of other species of
tarantulas I mean a tarantula is not
just one thing but
like like you said I had heard of other
spiders I'm like usually the females eat
the males like a lot of times yeah the
males are trying to get away though and
a lot of times they do get away right
yeah they don't always but yeah that's
kind of a pretty common it's just
dangerous because they eat each other
yeah well I I guess that's why the um
the female spiders live and the females
are usually bigger than the male so you
know yeah they do probably go the other
way around if
if the if the male was bigger than the
female he'd probably impregnate her and
then eat her too you know they're
spiders they're like hey free food yeah
but they they've ensured that the male
is smaller so she survived a snack
because if he was bigger the females
would not survive and the species would
vanish
so they made sure the males are smaller
so they can't eat the female but the
female can eat them yeah
but sometimes she does that's her
prerogative man she's a spider that
Goblin said oh good I came in on
tarantula porn we had chances eating
sorry I mean there are a lot of
tarantulas in this episode so we got
distracted and they they I mean in in
our defense they did bring it up with
that whole mate for life thing which
like I said so I did look it up because
that's that's not true as soon as they
said that I looked at Jenny and I was
like that's true that can't be I was
like I don't think that's true yeah
arthropods and insects aren't like that
they don't usually do that kind of [__]
I mean some other animals do but spiders
I don't think so
so uh so yeah so both of the daughters
uh start school and Dennis starts his
new job so Candace as in many of these
episodes gets left alone in the house oh
the poor ladies always left alone in the
house while dad's at work and the kids
are at school and just always there
alone and I write in my notes ooh limo
um I guess because because they have
that scene where it's like oh the kids
are going to school and they get in the
back of a limo I was like oh must be
nice okay that's not really a big deal
when you're working for a company well I
know that but I'm just saying that it's
like I mean for me it would be a big
deal usually usually what the deal is is
that they can't send the kids on public
transportation because it's buses and
they stick out like a sore thumb they'll
Rob them or [__] you know hassle them
so they have to be driven to school I
mean some of these schools don't have
school buses so the company
has a driver
and they drive the kids to school in a
company car that's usually how the [__]
goes down not really a chauffeur as you
would know it he's not into beck and
call at any moment he's just on a
schedule there was a lot of that in
Brazil yeah he's like I'm not driving
you to [__] Hooters right it's not
like that it's just that they're gonna
make sure they're just trying to keep
the employees families happy now you'd
be like well that's a big expense no no
not in those countries that dude's a
minimum wage level a little bit above
minimum wage actually
um because he has to have a driver's
license
he'd probably think it's a pretty good
job but uh
in US Dollars a dude's probably making
about 200 250 bucks a week that's that's
probably and which would he you could
live okay okay on that
you know but that's those big companies
no that's nothing for them
well no I'm just saying that it's like
obviously the way I grew up that would
that's like a big deal because I didn't
know anybody that had that kind of sugar
yeah when I went to high school in
Brazil I think they were all like that
well I know you pretty much but but my
school had a bus so most people just
took took the bus
let's go ahead we had a whole Fleet of
buses God I hated the bus I always I
always loved the bus I always made a
[__] relative take me to school
because I love the book I didn't want to
go on the [__] bus that school school
bus was not [__] it wasn't a bus like
a yellow school bus it wasn't like that
oh yeah it was like a uh like a tour bus
you know I mean or like a greyhound
style bus with sliding windows and we
get in the back we'd smoke weed or smoke
cigarettes listen to [__] headphones
and it was never really full
yeah I mean they didn't have that many
students each bus it was fun it was a
party school
well like I said that's part of school
other other people didn't have that same
experience yeah so
not not fun for the rest of us oh we
loved it so uh so yeah
so Candace like I said home by herself
kids are at school uh Dennis at work
so the first thing she said now I guess
this was kind of like a bigger deal than
the way she described it but she said
that she's unpacking again and she
started seeing like weird flashes of
light or like orbs of light like out of
the corner of her vision like she keeps
seeing this weird [__] and it's like it
was weird enough I guess that she would
see it and then she'd be like what the
[__] was that and then like go into
another room like to check out what it
was but there was never anything there
um and she's like whenever I had turned
like to look at it like it wasn't there
like I said so it sounds like it's not
that big a deal but she was acting like
it was a big deal so it must have been
like pretty [__] weird
but it was like lights she was seeing
so she wasn't sure what to do so she
tried to call Dennis at work but I guess
like he wouldn't answer and then she was
like you know [__] this I'm not gonna
tell anybody about it because maybe
everybody will think I'm nuts or
something
now a few nights after this Marissa who
I he's she's the younger daughter right
she was 12. so she's sitting at the
dining room table like doing her
homework or whatever
and she thinks that she sees somebody
out the window like out in the yard like
walking by the window
so her sister Stacy comes down and she's
like hey I'm pretty sure I just saw
somebody out the window and Stacy looks
out there but she doesn't see anybody
and then Marissa came on because they
had both the daughters on there like uh
you know they're grown obviously but
they were both on there talking and
Marissa said that she like her mom she
often saw things out of the corner of
her eye
um and couldn't really explain what they
were like weird lights or Shadows or
something like that that was kind of
like the first thing they saw and also
she said she heard kind of like weird
noises I suppose
so one thing they had to do because of
the tarantula problem was that before
you went to bed I'd and I kind of
related to this really hard because some
houses I grew up in I was like well you
always had to do like a cockroach check
like before you went to sleep so that's
what she did
um she would do a spider check like in
her room making sure there's no [__]
tarantulas like under the pillow or
anything like that
so at this stage Stacy who's the older
daughter she's in her room and she's
like sitting in her bed like reading a
book or whatever
and she said that she started hearing
footsteps walking into her room she said
she heard it very very clearly as though
somebody like creaking like walking into
her room but obviously she didn't see
anybody
and then she hears a voice Whispering
her name in her ear
and the way they had it as I guess it
was a male voice I'm assuming that's
what they did on the show
she didn't say that specifically oh my
phone's ringing [__] hopefully that's
not anything like important
it's right there
what does it say on it it's right there
it's right there right there right there
oh well I missed it
I missed it I don't know who that was I
mean it's kind of late so
I don't know who that one I don't know
who that is I don't know who that is
it's a it's a local number but I don't
know who that is
um okay so where was I so yeah so she
hears footsteps like coming into her
room but doesn't see anybody
and then here's somebody whispering in
her ear now again she doesn't tell
anybody either so I kind of feel like
the mom and the daughters are
experiencing things like separately but
didn't tell each other which is kind of
common on these episodes they start you
know because you you see or hear
something like that and they're just
like well maybe it's just me like maybe
I'm losing my mind or something like
that so you don't tell anybody because
they would think you were not so they
wouldn't listen or something like that
so uh at this point the rainy season in
uh Taiwan has started again and uh you
know like we figured before the house
leaks so basically water is just running
down the [__] walls and Candace the
real Candace she says on there well the
light switches in the house were not
grounded
so basically we had to have broom
handles like all around so you could
turn the lights on and off like from the
switch because if you touch the switch
you would electrocute yourself because
like the [__] walls are wet and they
and nothing was grounded so she's just
like you know what I mean there's like
[__] Sparks everywhere which is crazy
um so
she's basically like this is such
[__] I'm like I agree that's
[__] I mean if that was the company
was paying for that house or was like
you know giving you a deal on that house
or something like that like fix that
[__] holy crap that's like unacceptable
they got that [__] on the [__] on the
slick
probably it's not the company company
got a great deal on it because it was
crooked I'll generate well I mean they
did kind of go into that a little bit
later I don't know if the if any of the
stuff they said about it was true or not
but you know what I mean
um so at this point uh the dad
you know the the where's that raccoon
guy he's yelling at the mom and the
daughters because their electric bill is
eleven hundred dollars a month yeah like
this month it was like eleven hundred
dollars and he's like what the [__]
where's that raccoon like why is this
1100 and they're like bro we don't know
it's like you know what I mean it's like
talk to your company about fixing this
[__] because we got water [__]
running on our walls and like
electrocuting us and stuff when we try
to turn the lights on so don't talk to
us about an electric 1100 electric bill
[__] I'm just saying so they
don't really know like apparently no
reason for it to be that high
so Dennis actually calls out an
electrician and the electrician
allegedly uh finds an underground power
leak or suspects that there's an
underground power leak now what they
said on the show I don't know if this is
true or not but they said the house
might have been built illegally which
wow um you know building a whole entire
Mansion like illegally out in this all
right I don't know they got away with
that but now I inter yeah yeah well they
said it was built illegally and not
properly connected to the grid that's
what they said on the show I don't know
what that means I'm gonna tell you what
I think that that means
I think what they meant is that the
house was not built to code
that when they built the house they
bribed officials off to pass it but it
didn't pass any of the damn inspect the
codes the the the the the construction
codes it's probably what they're talking
about yeah you can't illegally build a
house that's what I was thinking I was
like that was a weird way of putting it
yeah because I'm like people wander by
and be like excuse me what what what's
that doing there you have to own you
can't put that there you got to hire
contractors to come and build it there's
a bunch of stuff but I think what they
meant is is that it was it was
um
it was illegally approved uh in other
words it did not pass building
inspection codes yeah but they bribed
everybody to get it to pass that's what
that's what the deal well I mean clearly
construction shitty probably what was
going on because it was like at the base
of the mountain and they said that every
time it rained because it's you know
Taiwan has like a big long rainy season
and they're like the water would just
come down the mountain and would just
like come in the house it it leaked and
it had shitty electrical system
and it's not built to stand not built to
code right but that's what they're
talking about
illegally built that's kind of a stretch
it's not really a good way to put it
that's what I mean it was just funny the
way that they phrased it that way
because I was like that would be it
takes a while to build a house I don't
think you could like keep it under wraps
for that long yeah I'm just saying
no and then and then pawn it off onto
people
yeah you're a big company uh here's the
house try this
oh that looks good
uh Ben says I live in Australia don't
talk to me about your tiny benign house
spiders
right yeah Australia has all the things
that want to kill you
so uh so Stacy the older daughter is
home alone a few nights later
and she uh sees the front door like I
said it kind of looks like the whole
front of the house is glass I don't know
what the real one looked like but this
one kind of look it looked like a hotel
lobby or like a Bank lobby or something
but she like the front door opens by
itself
and then
stays open for a few minutes and she's
like what the [__] like she thought that
her family had come back home or
something like that but nobody was there
so it just like stayed open for a few
minutes and then it closed by itself
again and then she's like all right [__]
that noise and like runs back to her
room which you know understandable
so yeah so she's afraid like something
bad might be going on
now
because of the that she suspected that
the house might be haunted so she had a
boyfriend whose name I think she said
his name was Thomas
and so she just goes over his house all
the time like just to get out of her
house because it's like she does I guess
she's alone all the you know in the
house a lot and she just like doesn't
like to be in there because it's [__]
creepy
so she goes over there all the time
but one night I guess she was over there
and then she came home and then she's in
the house by herself and she's I put
she's making sandwich because I was
trying to write back I was she's making
sandwich and she hears her name in her
ear again like something's in the
kitchen like
[__] saying her name
so she's like all right [__] this so she
goes to her boyfriend's house again and
tells him the whole [__] story she's
like look there's all this kind of
creepy [__] there's some ghost like
saying my name and opening doors and
whatnot and I don't like it
now one particular night
um him and uh I guess his dad like drove
them around yeah Jen's making this sound
real real light-hearted she was [__]
terrified though uh she's walking around
that creepy ass house hearing this thing
behind her call her name and she turned
around just watching her
now I don't know what it was watching or
if it was watching her undress or
something but I think that's what they
were alluding to
there was something in there stalking
her like that and then she told her
boyfriend about him
and what did he do about it he was
teenage boy at high school you know yeah
I mean well at least he was like
supportive he wasn't yeah there's a
ghost in there [__] yeah he wasn't like
whatever it's getting rapey oh [__] so I
was like all right good on me bud I
don't know if that was like what the
real guy was like maybe the real guy was
like what the [__] are you talking about
shut up the impression that it was uh
it it had it had a it had a it had a
fetish for foreign women
yeah they wanted some foreign
they're all like watching you pee and
stuff weirdos no she said it said her
name perfectly
so it didn't say it within with an
accent or anything yeah cause I was like
why is that go speaking English did it
speak English I don't know I don't think
she it really only it really only just
said their names I guess I think it just
said their names so
but I don't see why
a ghost would have to learn your
language it would probably understand
what you were thinking through telepathy
and just give you because it could it
could feel and read your mind and then
just instantly make a reply in your own
language probably you wouldn't have to
learn your language it would do it
automatically probably
yeah I kind of feel like that would be
pretty lame if like ghosts could only
speak the language yeah like I can't
speak the language something you know I
can't honest like what what I can't want
you right yeah yeah that'd be like
something you hear like voice in your
ears like what are you saying I don't
understand you or I would send you a
telepathic message so strong you thought
you heard it and you thought you heard
it and understood it in English
you know yeah but the English would be
generated by you actually
One Way Or you could do it
but yeah so uh so one particular night
um they dropped Stacy back off at home
like I said I'm pretty sure the
boyfriend's dad like drove him around
so he went and dropped her off at the
house
and she goes back in the house there's
nobody else home by her and then when
Thomas and the dad are like pulling out
of the driveway Thomas happens to like
look back toward the house and he sees
what appears to be a woman standing on
the roof of the house
like on the reenactment they showed her
like looking all ghosty and [__] but
it's like I don't know if he they didn't
have him on the show so I don't know
what he actually saw but apparently he
saw something that looked like a woman
standing on the roof and he thought it
was Stacy's mom he thought it was
Candace like what the [__] is she doing
up there yeah because as soon as he got
home he called her and was like hey you
might want to go check on your mom
because I saw a woman that kind of
looked like your mom like standing up on
the roof of the house like in her
nightgown or some [__] and then it's
like maybe it's weird you know what I
mean yeah what was weird is when they
showed it in the episode it didn't like
she was standing on top of the house
looked like she was standing on top of a
fence didn't it
or a wall
I couldn't really tell it just kind of
looked like part of the roof or
something yeah I thought that she was
like standing up there
now meanwhile like before he calls
though like while he's still on the way
home like Stacy goes in the house and
it's super quiet in there and she's like
um yeah she doesn't think anybody's home
and then when she goes in her room like
somebody says her name like in her ear
again and then she hears like it sounds
like chittering sounds it's kind of
sounded like the noises that they were
using for the spiders earlier and then
there's a phone jump scare like the
phone rings really loud and everybody's
like oh my God you know what I mean
um but it's just her boyfriend calling
being like hey check on your mom I'm
pretty sure I saw her standing on the
roof which is like weird as [__]
she comments in the episode
that it was it was bizarre that you that
it could didn't she say it could open a
door and walk right up to you you
couldn't see it and it was
say your name just out of the fit and
just get out of the air and it's like it
was
like just as plain as day
yeah yeah she said it would say a name
well she said that it would say her name
like just in her ear or like from across
the room or something like that yeah
which yeah that would be pretty creepy
like yeah if I was just like sitting in
here and somebody said a name and said
my name in my ear yeah you probably [__]
my pants you know what I mean that
Poltergeist tried to speak that one time
but I couldn't understand what it said
it was just gibberish that was weird
that [__] I need to jumped out of my
skin [__] jumping up out of the bed
and ran from it it was weird talk about
it in the book
Zach said to Stacy's mom got it going on
yeah yeah she does yeah they were all
cute no it's that's a that's a song all
right um so yeah so Stacy is in the
house not sure if anybody's in there so
she keeps calling her mom like hey Mom
hey Mom like nobody but Mom doesn't
answer right yeah so then she goes into
Mom's bedroom it's actually like a
pretty creepy sequence you know what I
mean and she goes in there and she's
like oh my God like opens the door but
then like her mom's just sitting on the
bed and she's totally fine like she's
sitting there in her jammies or whatever
and she's just like sitting there
reading a book or whatever
so she's like what the [__] mom like
didn't you hear me calling you she's
like I've been calling you all
throughout the house but her mom said
that she didn't hear her calling so I
was like I don't know if that was like
some kind of a paranormal thing too
where like the ghost was muffling the
sound or some [__]
so she goes and like calls her boyfriend
back and says yeah Mom's fine you know
when she's just sitting here and she
doesn't have any idea what the hell is
going on so at this point Stacy sits
down with her mom and tells her about
all of the [__] that she's been
experiencing the voices and the door
opening and closing and all that kind of
stuff and at this point Candace the mom
she says you know somebody's been saying
my name in my ear too and like so they
hadn't like been telling each other like
I said I went after all the women right
they hadn't really been like I said
these [__] perverted ghosts it's all
perverted man bad enough they're
perverted when they're alive and you
can't even get rid of them when they're
dead you can't even [__] see him like
I said they're watching you pee and all
kind of crap just this evil spirit
trying to have his way with these women
piss off ghosts and in here just this
helpless dude in your house and you
can't defend your own women against this
thing imagine that but what's funny is
that the husband doesn't seem to believe
in it
yeah and this is another case where like
his husband seems like he's never there
yeah he he kind of like well okay you
know that's he doesn't really believe
yeah I mean they kind of she kind of
said I don't think he necessarily
disbelieved us because all of them were
saying the same thing and they were all
clearly very upset but it's like he
didn't really know like he wasn't there
he didn't experience anything he
couldn't do anything he didn't really do
any he couldn't really do anything about
it yeah so you know he's just like well
I mean I don't know like I got a job to
do I got I will work to Doodle like
don't concern me with your petty little
problems I got money to make you know Ed
Dunham from uh Haunting in Florida who I
know him he's on my face he's my on my
friends list [__] met him a couple
times talked to him on the phone
the ex-army ranger he said he drove him
up the [__] wall that he couldn't
defend his wife and his family against
this day
and he just saw it a couple times dude
sitting there on the corner of the bed
[__] he said he looked [__]
blueish [__] smoking a cigarette just
staring at him he was wet he was like he
like he'd been
doused in water you know like he'd been
outside or something he said it was a
very uncomfortable feeling I can kind of
could kind of relate to it but I was a
kid so I didn't feel like I had when I
saw the Poltergeist thing so I didn't
feel like it was my responsibility to
protect anybody you know what I mean
but I could understand how a grown man
would feel the kind of the
responsibility to protect his family but
there's just no way
well I mean we've talked about this
before but on several episodes of a
haunting like the guys seemed
particularly upset about it because when
they finally because a lot of times they
won't see anything for a long time so
just be like oh would you ladies shut up
like what the hell are you even talking
about like when they when the women try
to like tell them what's going on but
then when they finally see it then they
like lose their [__] like they're just
like holy [__] like they can't even deal
with it and then like the women are just
like yeah duh we've been telling you
this the whole time like you just didn't
listen but then like they kind of like
flip out and I think even one of them
said this directly that it's like well
you can't like you can't punch it yeah
like and that's kind of like the only
thing they can think of to do it's like
you can't like knock a [__] a ghost the
[__] out well Ed Ed said that yeah
that's what I well I saw somebody else
on another episode said that same thing
so so they don't so they don't know what
to do they're like well if I can't punch
it then I'm I'm out of ideas you know
what I mean it's it's pretty much that
so so yeah so she does so they do like
Tell Dennis the dad
about it and like I said she's
she said it wasn't like he thought that
they were lying but it's just that he
didn't really he hadn't experienced it
so he was just like well what do you
want me to do he's like I can't really
tell my boss oh we have to move out of
this company house because it's haunted
it's like everyone you know I think he
was afraid like people were gonna laugh
at him or something like that
so Candace actually is like well all
right well I'll take this into my own
hands then so she starts like
researching the Paranormal and she's
like maybe if we like ignore it like
it'll go away because I feel like a lot
of um like priests and [__] like that
have been on a haunting have said that
too it's like don't give it any energy
so just kind of pretend it's not
happening which is you know easier said
than done obviously
um so Marissa the younger daughter she's
home alone one night like Mom and Dad
are at a neighbor's house like for a
party or something and Stacy is over at
her boyfriend's house
now while Marissa is home uh the front
door opens by itself again
um Marissa is in her room and she hears
noises downstairs like her parents or
her sister has come home because she's
down there being like hey you guys come
back did you forget something or some
[__] like that but she goes down there
and obviously nobody's there so she gets
like really freaked out and then she
runs back in her room and locks herself
in there
at which point the doorknob of her door
like she locks it but it starts rattling
and then the door like busts open
and then something like comes in and
puts white contact lenses in her
eyeballs she says it entered her
yeah this is what we were trying because
we were sitting there watching this
episode and I'm just like and we're like
well did she mean that like in the
biblical way like we're in a spiritual
way and then she's acting like she's
been victimized for a couple days you
know eating a cereal real slow and
everybody's like it's gonna be okay
I didn't know if they were trying and
like she didn't want to talk about it
yeah I didn't know if they were trying
to say that she had been sexually
assaulted
by the spirits I mean they use the word
attacked yeah on the on the reenactment
they just have like I said the door
rattled then it opened by itself and
then they just showed her going like
like that and then like she came up and
like her eyes were all white right so
but it should effect but she had never
seen that yeah that's what I mean so it
was like they left it very ambiguous
like what exactly happened yeah
um she basically said like the real
woman she said she used the word
something pushed her or pushed into her
um and then went inside her body that's
what she said yeah so I don't know if
she meant like
like like a rapey kind of way or if it
just like went like took over like a
possession kind of way you know I think
it was a rapey kind of way it said it
knocked her oh she said it knocked her
over knocked her over mounted her
which I think that's how I interpreted
it
I mean yeah I mean it could mean a lot
of things but yeah afterwards the way
the mom was acting and the way they're
showing her you know what I mean is that
it's like it's like it raped her
yeah and they said that she really
really did not want to talk about it
because she's just like yeah I'm fine
I'm fine you know what I mean and they
were kind of like yeah
so at this point uh Candace is starting
to get really worried because she's like
look this [__] is like attacking my kids
and that's not cool so she calls up a
journalist's friend of hers
who knew some
um like some Taoist priests because they
he had been like writing all about that
this is the great part whenever you see
the Taoist priest in this in this
episode they play the flute music
yeah Eastern flute music Eastern
spiritual flute music every time he
comes on it's [__] classic man that's
his theme song
[Music]
he has his own theme music when he comes
in to like deal with the spiritual world
yeah he said I wish I had my own theme
music when I walked in somewhere that'd
be rad
but yeah so uh so they bring this priest
over that this other guy knows and uh
the priest talks about he doesn't use
the term feng shui but I'm pretty sure
that's what he's talking about yeah he's
saying the feng shui this house is all
[__] up yeah he doesn't say that but I
think that's what he meant yeah I think
that's what he meant because that's how
Westerner would understand it that's
what I mean because basically Mojo of
this house is all [__] up right well
because he's like look all this water
that's happening in here this is like
bringing in all the negative energy and
he said apparently according to them no
Chinese architect would build a house
like this unless they wanted to curse
everyone that was in it that's what he
said yeah and then they had Candace the
real woman and she took it up another
notch of drama and she's like basically
she said they built this house to kill
us yeah and I was like let's dial that
back let's dial that back a notch that's
like you know what I mean yeah nobody
built this house specifically to kill
you my more rational interpretation
of the testimony is this
whoever built the house didn't know
anything about feng shui right and the
priest showed up and says oh man the
feng shui of this house is awful like oh
you know who did this he said no no
Chinese feng shui artist would [__]
ever make a house shaped like this it's
it's it's filtering the negative energy
into here and doing this and it's just
concentrating and it's all bearing down
on you this house will [__] you up
and look they even cheaped out on the
[__] electrical system
yeah which doesn't have anything to do
with ghosts honestly that really needed
to be yeah you know
it's a good story
I think feng shui might have more to do
with uh just how you feel at the moment
it's probably oh yeah the flow well
because they've done tests where they
had different feng shui experts come in
and be like and everybody says something
different yeah because it's like
whenever
psychics well Well everybody's
experience is subjective it's like you
know I could walk in a house and be like
hey this is pretty awesome and like
another person could walk in and be like
ooh I don't like this you know what I
mean so it's just like you know it's
very subjective like how you feel at the
time yeah and I kind of feel like feng
shui is probably the same thing it's
like it's it's whether you Vibe with the
place or not yeah you know what I mean
it's not Supernatural but yeah he's just
saying well no Chinese person would have
built a house like this because it's
like super [__] up and you know it's
basically was built to
to kill people I guess
so uh so yeah so then he talks to them
about
as we were mentioning earlier quote
unquote hungry ghosts
hanging around because they still want
energy and stuff from the living or
they're mad that they're dead and still
want to enjoy things that they enjoyed
when they were alive like food and money
and whatnot
um so he apparently has a vision I had a
vision of two bodies buried on the
property that had died of violent death
and these were the hungry ghosts in
question so he basically says well we
need to do a ritual
because your youngest daughter Marissa
is being used by these hungry ghosts
like as an energy source that's what
they said
so then uh like many of the priests and
many of the other episodes it's like
well I need to like gather my strength
for this I can't just like do an
exorcism thing willy-nilly I gotta go do
fasting and whatever the hell it is they
do they gotta prepare he's gotta juice
up he's gotta juice up for the [__] yeah
Power Up you heard that when he said
that I was like okay he's probably the
real thing because I got a [__] I
gotta power up
I that one time I wanted to show Jen the
Poltergeist that took several months
for phenomenon to [__] but you
weren't powering up on purpose like it
just well I mean I don't think you were
you weren't right it was
sliding sideways with it
okay yeah you don't believe so well no
I'm just saying that I didn't think that
you felt like specifically like not
getting ready for it like yeah priest
would no no but you could though you
could yeah well he's like he's psyching
himself up so he's like well it's you
know it's gonna take a few days because
I got some [__] to do if Barbara sit
there and psych myself up get bring in a
lot of fear
like I'm terrified constantly make
myself afraid that it's gonna be here it
would it would eventually come
to start up
and then one phenomenon happens which in
reinforces it you know and it goes you
saw how it was yeah once you get the
ball rolling it it continues to it gets
easier
so uh so they said that the priest that
came in there that he actually seemed
afraid for the family so he's like you
know I'm gonna go power up and like I'll
be back in a few days to do the ritual
and hopefully get rid of these ghosts or
whatever
now the driver
um achang
it doesn't matter I mean I'm sure it
matters to him it's his [__] name
isn't it yeah
um but yeah I'm just saying so the
driver guy he's in Taiwan how do we know
we don't know so um so he's the driver
so they asked him about well do you know
anything about this property or anything
he said you know
um I heard that where this house is now
like prior to that that there was a pig
farm on this land and the pig farm
burned down and killed the couple that
lived that lived on the farm
um which maybe is the whole like yeah I
saw two bodies type situation and these
are the hungry ghosts that are coming in
there and like you know
terrorizing raping people and raping
people which you know not cool okay just
saying I I feel bad like just blaming
all the farmers they're like look we
just died in the fire Jesus Christ we're
not raping people from Beyond the great
piss off so it's that so Candace is like
once they find this out she's like I
really want to move like I don't want to
live here anymore
um and Dennis is like uh yeah well I
gotta go on a business trip I'm not
concerned about all your ghost danger
um you know what I mean I've read it
really big I'm not concerned about your
ghost danger because we were like
laughing about that because he was just
very he wasn't an [__] like because
some of the dudes like on this show
um are real
Conte like when it comes to kind of like
it's like what's ghosts and [__] right
they can make fun of you right and so
this guy wasn't that bad but he was just
he was pretty dismissive though he's
like look I got [__] to do I don't have
time to deal with this right now
um yeah it's probably bad and [__] like
that but you know I got a business trip
you just sort that [__] out it was kind
of like that kind of situation I was on
the impression that he thought of the
thought of it as like new agey girl
stuff he doesn't have anything to do
with that that's like that yeah you take
care of the ghost he did seem like a
very dudeley yeah that's some that's
some [__] girls are into like
right yeah he's like ooh that has to do
with like you know emotions and like
things that aren't concrete and so he's
like I'm I don't have any patience that
kind of stuff yeah he definitely did
come across yeah I can't do anything
about that like I said he didn't like
the real guy because he was on there so
I guess he did come around to it later
on because he did get interviewed for
the show he seemed to believe something
was going on there but he didn't see it
right he did think something was going
so he wasn't as bad as like some of the
people that have been on there that like
but he did seem very very straight laced
and he did seem very like
um I don't know it's like he didn't know
what to do it's like I don't know how to
deal with anything that's not
this kind of thing you know business
that's not very interesting he's just
like there's a suit you know yeah he
yeah he came across very much like that
so he's on a business trip so Mom and
the girls are in the house by themselves
uh they start all sleeping in the same
room uh with a knife and a bat and all
that other kind of stuff which I don't
know how useful that would be against a
ghost but I don't but I don't blame her
because just make you feel better yeah
what the [__] else are you gonna do
right yeah because that's what I was
thinking did that in a bad house [__]
him
sleeping [__] knock that ghost
block off sleeping with my [__] Ruger
GP100 [__] in my hand
afraid that thing was gonna [__] come
get me it never did though
it wasn't just me
what do you have tried to shoot the
ghost if I came out here yeah I wonder
what would happen it just went through
it you might have just made it mad well
the sound and the noise and everything
would have made me feel better yeah yeah
you know what I mean well I take it
action yeah I kind of feel like such a
holy totem or something like putting up
across just to make you feel better
right yeah it might not do jack [__] it
probably won't but Focus your psychic
Force at the thing [__] off me [__] off
me [__] and it'll probably go away
because you're believing in it you know
you believe in that it's gonna go yeah
maybe that's what it is right
so uh so yeah so then the show does a
little bit this is a little bit of a
cheat I feel like but they do this a lot
on the show
so they have this whole set up they're
all sleeping in the same bed like when
they got the knife and a bat and all
that other kind of stuff and then
they're in the mom's bedroom and the
doorknob starts rattling and like they
hear floor creaking like there's
somebody outside in the hall like trying
to get into the room
so uh you know the girls wake up and are
like Mom that's like
outside she's like yeah I hear it so she
grabs the [__] butcher knife and
she's like I'm gonna take care of this
[__] situation so she goes over their
door very very very slowly and then she
opens the door real quick and it's Dad
but she stabs him in the [__] stomach
like ow and I was just like holy [__]
and then like they showed that it was a
dream that one of the girls was having
like so the girl I think it was like
Marissa the younger one and she woke up
and she was like oh my God like I
dreamed that you killed dad and all this
other kind of stuff and I was like okay
but yeah so that was like a little bit
better that was a little bit of a cheat
like I said because I even wrote down
psych it's a dream
so uh so Dennis doesn't get stabbed but
you know somebody one of the girls
dreamed that Mom stabbed dad so might
have been some other issues going on
there
so Dennis comes home and he uh agrees to
have the priest come and do the whole
thing
so this also kind of made me laugh
because the Mom and Dad are sleeping I
don't know what time it was supposed to
be but they were both asleep so I'm
assuming it was like you know midnight
or something phone rings and they're all
like waking up and like what the [__]
and it's like the priest I gotta come
over and do the [__] right now like I
guess he's at maximum power up I'm like
maximum power i'm like [__] are you
calling me at two o'clock in the morning
to come exercise my house right now can
you wait till the morning I'll even make
you some bacon come on so now I gotta
blow this wad right now
ready I was like that's very adventurous
don't be like calling people in the
middle I don't care if there is a
haunting don't be calling me a two in
the [__] morning say oh I have to do
it right now no you don't you know he
had done something else didn't you have
some kind he had some other some other
paranormal not some other occult thing
had happened and he was coming off of a
[__] high it was a funeral funeral he
had done a funeral earlier that day for
like a very powerful individual so he
was feeling all the good mojo from that
and he's like okay well all the good
mojo is built up so I have to come over
like right now and I'd be like I think
I'd be a little upset if somebody called
me at two in the morning and said that
I was like I don't think so man you had
to go in there with maximum positivity
this is a good part of the episode
though man yeah yeah it's a fun episode
I was just that that occurred to me I
was like yeah you don't ever call me in
the middle of night though somebody's
dead seriously that's [__] up he goes
in there and does his does the they do
the Far East music and everything and
he's dispelling the evil and driving it
out
uh he's in his uh Taoist priest outfit
you know it's pretty slick they're
they're they're observed and the whole
family including the guy observes some
paranormal some paranormal phenomenon
lights dimming and stuff while he was
walking into rooms and no it sounded
legit to me man I'd like I wish I was
there to see it
yeah I mean the priest comes over and
he's basically like okay we're gonna do
the thing and he's like we have to open
all the doors like to give the spirits
free movement or whatever and then he
brings food and money and all that kind
of stuff I think he actually did bring a
pineapple there was one in the box
that's why I was laughing at like bring
the ghost to Pineapple yeah but you know
pineapples are good you know that's you
know that's that's fair
um you know he likes incense and stuff
and like I said yeah he said he'd had
like a funeral for the guy earlier and
that was like yeah all that
um so at this point like I said there
had to have been some kind of like
Paranormal Activity because the dad who
didn't believe in this [__] before he
actually did allow himself to be
interviewed like on the show the real
guy so and he said there was definitely
like some [__] going on like when the
priest was doing the ritual like things
they said that [__] started like moving
around yeah did he get any details did
he well they basically said well their
hair was blowing and their clothes were
blowing I was like well was that because
all the windows and doors were open or
you know whatever it could have been
that
um but they said they felt like things
were moving through them maybe I think
like one of them said that we said the
lights would Dim when he would walk into
a room yeah they said it was very
physical whatever it was that happened
that was pretty much all they said
um and at this point like the priest
tells Stacy the 16 year old um you have
to take these offerings like the food
and money and stuff out to this grave
site where supposedly these two bodies
are buried out in the backyard and she's
like why the [__] I gotta do that and
she's like yo you just have to do it
that's just the rules
um you know just be brave don't be [__]
like go out there and do it right so
take the basket out there she's in her
jammies and everything so she takes his
basket outside and she hears somebody
calling her name like from all around
like in the woods and stuff and she's
just like uh here goes bye and then she
like runs back in the [__] house you
know what I mean puts the basket there
now the priests like they said he went
to every room and he like prayed in each
corner of every room and the lights
dimmed like you said like every time
that he went into the room and like did
his thing
um and then like at this point like the
dad Dennis he was like well we thought
that the priest came in and did and did
the thing and then it was going to be
over and it's like oh yeah we can like
live in the house and it'll be normal
now but then the priest tells them it's
like oh well this should hold you over
for two or three months yeah um but I
would still advise moving the [__] out
of here because this is like not a good
situation
yeah so we can live here now and he said
oh no no no no no no I just I just
bought you some time you gotta go
yeah he's like this is not a good place
to stay um You probably he's like it'll
probably be better for a couple months
but I would advise getting out of here
which you know fair enough
um so yeah
I find all this stuff interesting first
of all the the claims of the case are
not all that extraordinary there isn't
any real [__] outlandish reports of
of [__] um phenomenon nobody saw any
demons
they did see physical phenomena of the
[__] lights dimming uh they reported
[__] sexual assaults I guess
um voices
and in the end the um
the Taoist priest didn't didn't come in
as the hero to to prove the validity of
the church per se like you like it in a
lot of the other stories he's like no no
you got to go yeah you know I feel like
I bought you some time you know you're
you're kind of in good standing with him
for right now but that should wear off
you gotta go
it's that kind of made that kind of
matches up
with what I would what I would say be
more likely haven't dealt with [__] like
this before no real permanent Solutions
things kind of fade away but that was a
bad house you couldn't stay there
if what they're saying is true
wishing it away or praying it away
wouldn't wouldn't work you're dealing
with something that's got a amazing
willpower
you know and it's in another dimension
so you know what I liked that the priest
was very realistic about that yeah he's
basically like well I didn't fix it
yeah I just bought you some time but I
placated it for a while he's like I I
think you should get out okay because
it's like it's not good so uh so yeah
and apparently the family did take it
seriously because they said as soon as
Stacy graduated from high school
um the mom and the daughters moved out I
don't know they didn't really say if the
dad
stayed yeah they they allude they
basically make you think that he stayed
there I mean I thought that was the
implication because they just said the
mom and the daughters moved out but he
wouldn't have been there for very long I
think what about six months yeah I think
yeah yeah so maybe he found another
place like afterwards I don't know if he
remained like living in Taiwan because
it was a company house they didn't have
to pay rent there probably yeah you just
had to pay utilities and it was like a
thousand a month for the electricity
that one month that might have been
because water was leaking and it was
shorting out into the into the ground
or you know yeah
so when it was dry that probably didn't
happen because it really wasn't wired
right
so um no I I was left with the
impression that they left and he stayed
there for about another six months yeah
until maybe whatever like the job was
over until this job was over until they
could get him like more different
accommodations or something like I think
he went back home didn't say he went
back home I think his job was over it
was like a contract
I don't know if they said that though
but like I said he had they hadn't come
from the U.S they came from Tokyo yeah
they had lived in Tokyo prior but they
went back to the U.S yeah I think well
the yeah the mom and the daughters yeah
for sure but it's like I was assuming
that they were still like married or
whatever because they were all on the
show like it wasn't like you know what I
mean I was left for the impression that
she said that he would have to be there
about six months and then they would
meet up with him later yeah I mean I
don't remember them saying that but I
mean they might have but I didn't write
it down okay and usually if they'd have
said that I probably would have written
it down because I remember I was like
that dude stay there by himself but he
didn't seem to have anything to report
but they but they had the ritual so
maybe yeah
got rid of it for a while yeah and he
was just like oh it's totally normal in
here and then he moved out and nobody
said anything about it and like I said
there's not really any uh I couldn't
really find any outside supplemental
material about this case so it's not
like somebody else moved into that house
later and was like holy [__] there's
like [__] ghosts and tarantulas and
[__] like all over the place you know
what I mean ghost tarantulas even yeah
so I don't really know but yeah so uh
yeah so this was a fun episode I think
this was the reason that I always liked
this episode was because so many of the
episodes you know are good but a lot of
them are very samey
and this was kind of one of the very few
that was set in a different culture with
like a different mythology and like a
different way of coming at it so I
thought that was kind of cool that and I
kind of wish they had done that more to
be honest with you they did do it like
they did do it more like on later
episodes but then they just it just got
silly you know what I mean like this one
was they run they run they're running
out of cases the case is right so now
they're just kind of having to scrape in
the bottom of the barrel with cases yeah
big time
big time yeah uh but yeah so I guess
we've been going for an hour and 22
minutes yep so I guess we better wrap it
up because I gotta start my job tomorrow
so I gotta get up real early
probably uh quarter to six I would
imagine all right because I probably
have to leave here about quarter to
seven all right so
so I can get there in time
so we are actually going to do a movie
review tomorrow
and it's going to be Gattaca because we
watched Gattaca last night great flick
but it's good to see it yeah but it's
gonna be later I'm thinking maybe seven
seven thirty
something like that because I probably
won't be home until six something yeah
Ethan Hawke and Uma Thurman and Jude Law
yes good science fiction movie from the
90s I had forgotten how old that movie
was classy science fiction movie it is
very classy but yeah so we'll be talking
about that tomorrow but like I said
it'll be later than usual because I
won't be uh I won't be home in time to
do it so it'll probably be like much
later in the evening but we are still
gonna do it and we already watched it
and I already got notes for it and
everything like that so hopefully you'll
be able to drop by and see us uh for
that thank you everybody for dropping by
today remember to like and share and do
all that kind of stuff uh because it
helps with the little YouTube algorithm
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
night good night